think of ballet nutcracker maybe comes
to mind or swan lake
but probably not this
[Music]
in the 1920s in germany the bauhaus
design revolution took off buildings
like this were out
minimalism was in but beyond
architecture many spheres of art were
touched by the baja school including
ballet
[Music]
trading ballet has been created by oskar
schlemmer oskar schlemmer wanted to find
a form for
new way of dancing bauhaus went down to
the functionality that's why he also
created costumes which would throw away
useless decoration the tiaras the tutus
the golden costumes
the avant-garde ballet debuted in 1922
and it was made into a film adaptation
by the bavaria atelier in 1970
then in 1977 it was recreated giving
birth to the version which yvonne now
directs
so the costumes relate
to geometric forms
that's why it's called triadic three
forms
it's a square it's a circle it's a
triangle there are three parts in that
valley it's the yellow part
pink
and black
[Music]
the costumes schlemmer wanted them to
restrict the dancer not to have the
complete freedom oskar schlemmer spent
lots of his money investing into the
costumes went so far that his family
when needed money he said sorry guys i
have to work on the costumes
you have to eat a little bit more modest
and it seems like schlemmer's labor of
love paid off
even today the geometric costumes
combined with the robotic dance
movements gets the audience's attention
you could hear people giggling in the
darkness because
the movements
it's very successful because
audience can't believe that this is 100
years old because it looks like it has
been done today there you see the
visionary power of oscar schlemmer and
the ideas of bauhaus and that's what
this ballet
gives you
[Applause]
[Music]
you